les autres ont tués et arrêtés les
autres joslet sioui présentera au salon
du livre des premières nations un
collage inédit de son livre mon nom
jules un fascinant récit sur l'activiste
jules si oui écrit en mode survie
mais rien est en train de mourir j'ai eu
une greffe de rein donné par mon père en
fait puis cette histoire l'homme dont le
jeune ben c'est ma survie mais c'est la
survie ou si de l'histoire autochtone le
gouvernement en a assez des frasques des
managers pandémie oblige ce salon du
livre sera sur internet
l'occasion est trop belle d'offrir des
balados des conférences et des lectures
de son salon dave jenniss lire un texte
sur l'identité la mort et le temps qui
passe dans mes écrits c'est souvent se
soient ralliés à seule identité la mort
mais le territoire l'animal est toujours
présent dans notre se pisser srna être
aussi de la mort par l'animal elle m'a
appris à écrire les noailles - avec
d'autres invités comme joséphine bacon
l'édition 2020 du salon sera une des
plus imposantes
ça vient vraiment donner une des
générals je pense au grand public de la
richesse et de la diversité de la
littérature autochtones d'aujourd'hui
c'est évident qu en étant sur le web on
atteint
on ose espérer qu'on va atteindre un
public beaucoup plus large
loki si le courant jusqu'au bleu du ciel
au delà du salon à longueur d'année des
auteurs comme naomi fontaine natasha
khan ap fontaine michel jean et marie
andrée gueule faut briller la
littérature autochtone si nous les
québécois on aime de plus amples la
littérature autochtone piquant
on en achète de plus en plus on adhère à
ça c'est beaucoup parce qu'on se
reconnaît dans le combat des attaques
tonnes je me suis demandé quel trajet
les laisser je serais si oui espère
présenter mon nom de jules sur scène en
2021 en attendant il se réjouit de
l'accueil réservé aux livres autochtone
vous pouvez toujours allez écrire votre
récit sur wikipédia d'ailleurs quand on
ouvre la porte à des autos à des gens
qui veulent prendre parole des gens
partant il ya plein de belles choses qui
se passent puis je pense que c'est
exactement ce qui se passe avec la
littérature autochtone temps qui
propulse à terre j'ai décidé de raconter
son histoire jusqu'à plus soif
ici louis fait depuis mai radio-canada
moria je ne manque pas d'enthousiasmé
croyez moi